let's jump into this first story take a
look at this image from CNN millions in
U.S under air quality alerts as Canada
wildfires rage you know
we're mostly a political cultural and
news show but I think this story is so
pressing that uh we probably should at
least talk about it a little bit because
this is going to directly impact you and
it directly impacts us the concern that
I have of course is uh for the chickens
because uh the this garbage falls on the
ground yeah and when we had the East
Palestine thing when they're saying all
those chemicals were blasting up into
the air and floating floating out of
here chickens were dying and so uh I'm
being somewhat Silly by referencing
chickens but when the when when this
stuff settles and gets all over the
grass and gets all over everything
that's going to cause problems too so
basically there's wildfires up in Canada
FAA has issued ground stops in New York
because the air quality was so bad you
couldn't actually see where we are in DC
apparently we're being told that it's
going to get worse tomorrow and it's
going to persist in New York and on the
East Coast until tomorrow as well so I
don't know how many of you guys are
experiencing this but you know this is
this is the latest we have this map here
record smog levels in Northeast and
right now you can see it's mostly bad in
the New York area it's going to come
down and heavily hit DC tomorrow so
apparently they're saying like where we
are it's gonna this guy's gonna turn
orange or something you know all the
talk we talk about war and chaos and
politics and stuff man it's these
natural disasters that can really
annihilate a civilization oh yeah this
is just a taste yeah I mean I flew in
through this today I landed in DC from
South Florida at about uh I don't know 2
30 p.m and uh I was running around to
get to the airport this morning I had no
idea I'm shaming to say I saw some
things on Twitter about Canada I really
had no idea what was going on until the
Pilot mentioned it I noticed we had it
was pretty clear I mean some clouds a
little bit of bombs but it's mostly
clear and then this weird Haze started
but we weren't hitting turbulence you
know so when you're typically on
approach you come through the clouds you
bounce in a bit it was dead smooth and
the pilot came already said oh if you
notice you can't see the ground it's
this air from Canada I was still I still
had Wi-Fi and I checked it out and I'm
actually driving after I see you guys
I'm gonna start heading to New York for
a family uh event and I just I'd pinged
my nephew before we went live and I said
how's the air quality said it's
absolutely terrible like can't see your
hand in front of your face yo check out
this real bad just keep talking about
let me play this video check this video
out so the point I was gonna make is Ian
I think you made a very good point about
the fact that people don't consider
natural disasters and or at least enough
especially as modern people because we
like to think that we're in control of
everything we can solve all of our
problems there's nothing unforeseen
that's going to knock us over and what's
strange is even when we are confronted
by natural disasters like this people
still want to try to claim that we're in
control of them this happened because
we're you know burning too much uh CO2
or putting too much of it out into the
atmosphere here this is a human
invention if we only behaved better and
didn't make the weather so angry this
wouldn't occur like we can't accept that
some things are just out of our control
yeah that's a good point man it's it's
very freaky to say like we are not in
control of this life like at any moment
a meteor could strike and set the world
on fire again yeah a global flood
something could knock out the sun like
block it block out the sun like this
kind of thing kill all the crops for
three to four years vast migrations and
and I was gonna say suicide and you know
the politics of this is they're saying
it's climate change no exactly exactly
they're like this is climate change it's
happening now everyone quick it's all
man-made that's what I'm saying we have
to make it our fault we have to put
place it under our control but sorry no
no no I'm just gonna say I disagree with
you guys I I look I I learned from the
Democrats Al Gore created fire in 2001
that's right created everything
it was a DARPA project he invented the
internet then he flinton's deal he
created fire and uh here we are now so
we should have listened so what is this
I'm not this is a joke is this a CIA op
to go like buyers in Canada to get a
false flag
Oregon Washington California have these
wildfires they're never called toxic
what the hell is in the Canadian
wilderness that's Landing orange
toxicity whatever it is for a long time
apparently yeah what is causing
something wrong that's why maple syrup
trees are burning and the air is moving
down and everyone's freaking out it was
kind of crazy I woke up and uh because
where we are you have you can see the
mountains yeah and there's like a white
fog it's like I hate right yeah yeah
it's a haze and I was like oh that's
kind of weird and then I smell burning
that's the crazy thing you can smell
like well when I landed yeah like when I
landed at Reagan today it smelled like a
campfire out there I mean it was real
noticeable but I haven't been checking
it uh is did they get an indication how
it started I don't know if you guys
that's what I'm looking at next time it
was climate change yeah it certainly was
just yeah we're driving an SUV that's
why I drive a diesel pickup so I might
be totally literally it is entirely your
fault I saw a video of a helicopter
laying Napalm to a bunch of trees but I
don't think that was it that'd be crazy
it's just really really that's not going
on the CNA
grabbing for straws this is air America
wildfires which indicates that they were
naturally formed well I mean I guess a
human could cause a wildfire I mean
often these things are arson but from
what I've been reading it didn't they're
saying it's normal I think it's just
higher than normal fire activity that
makes sense and so they say because
humans have been pumping so much CO2 in
the atmosphere it's causing a slightly
more higher temperature which means a
little bit drier which means more fire
and you know there is something to that
we go a little out of balance and it can
send the whole thing out out of whack so
that we do have to be careful with CO2
levels but that doesn't mean cease
production just got to figure out how to
reuse the stuff or or continue to reuse
the stuff yeah you know I think part of
this instinct to blame this on man-made
climate change firstly it's very
convenient because you get to blame it
on your political opposition if you're
on the lap like literally everything is
the fault of conservatives you go
outside and you don't like the weather
it's like well this is some Republican
politicians fault surely it reminds me
of a quote from the one and only Thomas
Soul he said
you know good things just happen and bad
things are somebody's fault that is
exactly how we think that is just our
default pattern and so something like
the weather right is something like New
York being covered in this smog and it
traveling across the country well that
has to be somebody's fault like bad
things can't just happen or things that
bother me can't just happen I have to be
able to blame someone even in the Bible
it's the flood they said that God sent
the flood like why can't we just accept
that it could have just happened
he sent it I guess we have to blame God
for this one somebody had to do it I
mean look I live in Florida and they try
to tell you hurricanes are man-made I
mean like the Hurricanes never happened
before the Industrial Revolution I mean
it's bizarre we started doing that yeah
and honestly it was not a well-marketed
product people still don't like them but
someone started making them for some
reason I like the I like when they're
when they say tornadoes it's the highest
temperature on record and it's like and
how far back do the records
270 years
you can look back at the Ice uh uh
sheets they do the drilling they pull
out core samples and then they they
measure and all that stuff that I can
respect that but like there's so many
rhetorical tricks to blame anything that
can't be explained it's almost like the
Democrats are acting like Shaman coming
to the people and being like it's
because the gods are angry and you've
got to give me money and and do what I
say now yes well no that's a very
typical thing we see that throughout all
of human history a group of people who
are in power saying the reason the
weather is not favorable is because you
aren't obeying us and sacrifice your
kids exactly Human Sacrifice we need to
reduce the population size or else we're
going to get more climate change
sacrifice your children to the sun god
did they really sacrifice their kids to
affect weather I think so different yeah
I mean different groups of people the
Mayans apparently did so I guess how
many carbon credits does Baphomet take
to give us a break here totally offset
that different groups of people
throughout history have engaged in human
sacrifice and one of the reasons
depending on the triber group was okay
hold on hold on this is actually really
interesting this is from March 11 2019
National Post ancient civilization
sacrificed more than 100 of their
children to stop bad weather say
archaeologists
it's really funny because that's
basically what Democrats are saying now
when they write these stories saying
don't have kids because climate change
is getting worse yes they're like
they're not saying to literally take
your children and sacrifice them on an
altar they're saying forgo having
children make that sacrifice
pre-sacrifice well well no sacrifice
right your family sacrifice them by just
not having no no no it would be like
sacrificing it's not sacrificed in the
sense of you take a child and you put
them on the altar it's never never
happened also and I think you know this
is multifaceted so most people who don't
have children the people who choose not
to have children will often say things
like it's because I care so much about
the climate no it's not that's that's
almost certainly not right it's because
you want to have the Dual income no kid
situation going on most of the time and
you can acknowledge that don't don't sit
there and tell me it's because you care
so much about the climate I think that's
usually not the case but that said when
you look um in ancient Rome this is
something archaeologists have discovered
just in various periods you have like
increases in infanticide uh when people
were having more sacks and they were
having sex outside of marriage and they
didn't know what to do with the the
children and they weren't taking care of
them and you can imagine this being a
trend historically too I mean people
saying I have a child I don't want to
take care of them so I will sacrifice
them in trying to make their horrific
active and fantasied out to be something
Noble and good and so they say oh well
this is like for the sun god or this is
so that we have a better Harvest when in
reality they had that cruelty in them
and wanted to do it yeah so so right now
we're in a record low temperature for
actuated about it yesterday it was like
49 degrees at night and and it's crazy
it's like we're you know it's springtime
or whatever and uh no matter what
happens
the the climate change people always
have an argument as to why whatever it
is yes so they stop saying saying global
warming because it started getting we
started getting cold periods and they
said no no it's climate change and I'm
like dude it's a record low now it's a
record highlighter but no matter what
happens you keep telling me it's the
same thing exactly now I I have no
problem recognizing pollution and saying
like I don't believe the planet can hold
infinite humans that literally makes no
sense but don't come to me and tell me
no matter what happens it's perfect for
your argument exactly I mean maybe you
could make the argument yeah there is
such a thing as too much CO2 we want to
keep the elements in balance and it can
be bad for for life on the planet but if
you're going to sit here and tell me
that every single thing that happens
with respect to the climate is a result
of human behavior what you have is a
circular hypothesis because it started
with first it was global cooling the
world was going to freeze then it was
global warming and then it became
climate change okay you have to build a
predictive model that tells us what's
going to happen successfully instead of
just bashing us for not going along with
your cause and then blaming whatever
happens to happen on our bad behavior
because of your circular Theory thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time